ring his rook all the way into the
corner the other corner
and once white captures the black pawn
then the black work on the other side
gives
check and skewers there we go
wesley smiling what does that change
just knight takes night surely
magnus as well he's like what are you
doing mate what are you doing
but wesley he's trying to set one last
trick knight takes knight and next move
black's pawn will make a new queen
oh there's a trick there's one trick in
the position
what are you guys seeing now so if black
gives check now the movie wants to play
if the black group steps up one square
giving check
the white king will actually drop back
and okay we have to show this on the
board
in the current position um in now if
black gives check
it looks like this is about to be a
skewer uh okay we didn't see that move
but we have to show it this is a skewer
white king now if it takes the knight
just rook takes rook and black's gonna
win extra rook
rook and king easily beats a king but
wesley had a trap in mind if this had
happened wesley would step
back to this square saying yes you can
take my rook but if you take my rook now
it's stalemate the white king is trapped
and it's not in check and it would be a
draw
but wesley of course setting that trap
magnus didn't fall into it and if we go
back to the current game position black
has an extra knight and a pawn
this is going to win the game magnus
avoiding this clever stalemate trick
that's a nice idea by wesley that's very
instructive always look for chances
never resign 55 point advantage for
magnus crawls now
we are basically waiting for wesley to
resign unfortunately
i guess there is no hope yeah no hope
the black king nowadays just needs to
join the party at the right moment
actually wesley was threatening to play
rook takes pawn right there and
threatened the same stalemate idea but
no the game has ended magnus carlsen
ending the game with of nightfall he's
checking and he's about to win white's
rook
wesley resigns a win four magnus crawls
and ends the first game off today he won
the first match
i win here